[Musique]
l'an dernier le trio de rock romano
donnait des concerts accompagnés dans
leur 4 2 chambres mais autant de la
pandémie
le groupe annonce une série de concerts
très intime et avec distanciation
comment ça va se passer et coûte donc
c'est un spectacle pour une seule
personne ou deux si ces deux personnes
ne vivent sous le même toit
on leur faire chacun une chanson de leur
choix dans nos plus grands hits la
personne sera entouré de plexiglas et on
lui fait la chanson jouée dans les yeux
alors que tous les arts de la scène sont
sur pause
le groupe pourrait devenir le premier à
présenter dès la fin du mois un total de
72 concert intime
cette formule une chanson et puissant
vent sera sécuritaire affirme le cabaret
lion d'or le but c'est que les gens le
public ne se croisent pas donc ça va
être la même chose ou voir encore plus
sécuritaire que d'aller à la pharmacie
du coin les gens vont arriver à une
heure précise qui conseille aux gens
d'arriver avec un masque pour se
protéger protéger les autres même si on
travaille encore sur la scénographie
le concept fait un malheur sur internet
tous les billets vendus avec de leurs
pièces ont trouvé preneur en quelques
heures à peine il profits sont remis à
la centrale alternatif qui est un
organisme qui viennent en fait les
acteurs indépendants de la scène
musicale que ce soit des salles et
spectacles des artistes indépendants
[Musique]
lieberman aux veut respecter bien sûr la
loi alors si le déconfinement et
repousser les concerts seront retardés
mais nous on veut pas être hors la loi
dans ce sens que si le décor finement
est prévue est repoussée d'une semaine
deux semaines trois semaines mais le
spectacle aussi
l'annnonce de ses premiers concerts
intimes survient alors que demain mardi
le ministère de la culture aura une
importante rencontre de travail avec une
trentaine d'intervenants pour justement
discuter de la relance du secteur des
arts de la scène
bien entendu le modèle qui sera
présentée ici au lion d'or par les dix
recrues mais n'osent est une opération
qui ne sera pas viable à long terme ici
luigi de primes et radio-canada m'ont
rien